remember when Richard Dawkins gave
powerful arguments against the existence
of God
neither do I
Dawkins is one of the pioneering
ringleaders of that circus we call the
new atheism if you're not familiar with
the group the new atheism is like the
old atheism if the old atheism got
rabies
back in the 1980s and 1990s atheists
generally didn't care what other people
believed they were like oh if you think
your God and your book help you that's
fine for you but I don't need that
then Richard Dawkins and Sam Harris and
Christopher Hitchens came along and
turned that cute little atheist puppy
into Cujo
how did they do it
how did atheism go from Winnie the Pooh
to cocaine bear almost overnight
well Dawkins and Harris and Hitchens
were the first people to successfully
use cult tactics on a large scale with
atheists turns out if you want to
mobilize and weaponize your listeners
arguments and evidence just aren't the
way to go in the 21st century
manipulating people into joining and
expanding your group is massively more
efficient and effective keep in mind I'm
not advocating manipulation and cult
tactics I'm simply describing the world
we now live in
if you want a group that's going to
March out into the world and mindlessly
carry out your commands like drones you
need cult tactics you instill in your
followers and US versus everyone else
mentality it's us against the world
you give them an unmerited self-esteem
boost just for being in your group in
this case it's oh if you're part of our
group you're smart if you're not part of
our group you're dumb
you stir up their emotions and give them
a sense of urgency oh man Christians are
on the verge of forming a theocracy if
we don't stop this religion thing right
now we're all doomed
if you set up your group correctly you
can rely on peer pressure within the
group to keep members in line so if
someone starts asking the wrong
questions or doubting the group's
doctrines other members of the group
will shame that person into conformity
the most crucial step for someone like
Dawkins is convincing his followers to
let him do their important thinking for
them if you run into a Dawkins drone on
Twitter or in the comments section of
YouTube the Dawkins drone will tell you
how stupid you are for believing in God
but if you start asking questions you
find out very quickly that the Dawkins
drone has no clue what he's talking
about he doesn't know anything about
biology or cosmology or history or
philosophy or anything else that may be
relevant to the discussion
in fact there's a really good chance
that the Dawkins drone who's trying to
convince you to become an atheist can't
even spell the word atheist
I don't have any actual statistics but I
would estimate based on personal
encounters online that between one
quarter and one-third of Dawkins drones
can't spell the word atheist
but that won't stop them from telling
you how stupid you are for not
mindlessly siding with Richard Dawkins
the Zucker Nike of atheism
why are these Dawkins drones so
confident that there's no evidence for
the existence of God when they've
clearly never examined the evidence for
anything
well they really believe that they're
atheist Heroes Have carefully examined
the evidence and concluded that the
evidence is really really bad
the vast majority of the new atheists
that you'll encounter have never
actually studied any of the arguments
for theism instead they have extremely
devout dare I say it faith that their
leaders have carefully thought through
these issues for them
there's just one problem
the leaders of the new atheism haven't
carefully considered the evidence and
concluded that there's no evidence for
the existence of God
they've done something far simpler and
far more cult-like
they've constructed a methodology that
is absolutely impervious to evidence
the actual evidence for God's existence
is completely irrelevant to Someone Like
Richard Dawkins because he's using a
methodology that makes his ideology
immune to evidence
let me guess you Dawkins fans don't
believe me do you can't trust a theist
we're not in your group we're all dumb
can't trust an outsider
well let's turn to someone you can trust
Richard Dawkins you don't want to go
against him do you of course not
think about what it would do to your
self-esteem if you got kicked out of
your group and you didn't get to sit
around all day telling everyone else how
stupid they are
that would be as traumatic as an Andrew
Tate fan suddenly realizing that telling
women their inferior won't actually get
him a Bugatti
and the clips we're about to watch Peter
bagozian is interviewing Richard Dawkins
bagozian is the author of a manual for
creating atheists so you know he's going
to be nodding an agreement at everything
Dawkins says but after these two
atheists agree with each other that
there just aren't any good Arguments for
belief in God bogosian gets hypothetical
suppose God did exist what sort of
evidence could God give Dawkins that
could convince Dawkins to believe in God
given that the host of arguments don't
work what what would it take for you to
believe in God what would it take and as
we're about to see they're talking about
what it would take if theism were true
if God exists how could he convince
Richard Dawkins that he exists
well I used to say it would be very
simple it would be uh you know the
second coming of Jesus or a great big
deep booming baseball Robeson voice
saying I am God and and I created so he
used to say that the second coming of
Jesus or an audible voice from God would
convince him but then he realized that
these things wouldn't convince him at
all I was persuaded mostly by actually
Steve Zara who's a who's a regular
contributor to my website Richard
dawkins.net he more or less persuaded me
that
if you even if there was this this
booming voice and the second coming in
clouds of Glory
the more probable explanation is that
it's a hallucination or a
Conjuring trick by David Copperfield or
something
um notice if God did speak and if Jesus
did return coming on the Clouds Of
Heaven with Legions of angels darkens
still wouldn't believe in God because a
more probable explanation to him would
be that it's all a hallucination or a
magic trick
but they're not finished
so if you you know if you walked out in
there these globes that were spinning
around that said you know I am God
believe in me or the famous Krauss thing
you walk out into the sky and it still
spells out in the stars in different
languages I am God believe in me so now
we walk outside and we see a message
written in the stars the stars have been
rearranged so that they spell out I am
God believe in me in multiple languages
surely that would convince these guys
who always go where the evidence points
right well again the problem is it could
be a delusion but the other problem is
you'd have to rule out alternative
explanations
so there could be other explanations for
why a message about God Was Written in
the Stars you'd have to rule out
alternative explanations like the aliens
I mean you'd have to how could you rule
out well I mean there could be an alien
trickster culture or something huh we're
gonna get those little humans maybe
powerful alien tricksters wrote the
message in the stars as part of a cosmic
prank talks that law
um
uh any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic magic
being super Supernatural the Clark from
Clark's third law is Arthur C Clarke the
man who wrote 2001 A Space Odyssey
Clark's third law states that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic Dawkins
gives an example
if you were to if you were to fly a
Boeing 747 back to the Middle Ages you
would be greeted as God now what's your
point Richard an alien visitation any
any aliens who could actually visit us
would have to be so far beyond us in
their technology that they probably
could manipulate the Stars to to um
spell out words or geometric forms or
something like that aliens that
'll enough to reach us could also be
powerful enough to write out words in
the Stars so if we all walked outside
one day and we read I am God believe in
me written in the stars in multiple
languages we should definitely not
believe in God because that message
could have been written by alien
tricksters
so God audibly speaking to Dawkins
wouldn't convince him Jesus appearing at
his second coming wouldn't convince him
God writing a message in the Stars
wouldn't convince him what would
convince him
so that couldn't be enough so it so what
would what would persuade you
well I'm starting to think nothing would
nothing would
even if God showed up and started
blasting people with lightning bolts
that still wouldn't convince Dawkins
that God exists
and if you listen to the discussion it
sounds like Peter bagozian agrees
completely
if God exists there is absolutely
nothing he can do to convince Richard
Dawkins and Peter bagozian that he
exists why because they've adopted a
methodology that is completely
impervious to evidence
but there's more well I'm starting to
think nothing would uh which which is
which in a way goes against the grain
because I've always paid lip service to
the view that a scientist
should change his mind when evidence is
forthcoming did you catch that
Dawkins says that he's always paid lip
service to the view that a scientist
should change his mind in light of the
evidence he calls it lip service do you
know what lip service means
it means you say one thing but your
actions show that you don't really
believe what you're saying
so for all his talk about going where
the evidence points he admits that when
it comes to the existence of God
evidence is irrelevant because I've
always paid lip service to the view that
a scientist
should change his mind when evidence is
forthcoming the problem is I can't think
what that evidence would look like isn't
that interesting according to Richard
Dawkins not according to me according to
Richard Dawkins he will reject any
evidence for God's existence if God
speaks to him directly well that could
be a hallucination
if Jesus returns in the clouds well that
could be a magic trick
God writes a message in the stars in
multiple languages well that could be
alien tricksters trying to trick me
notice the guy who has dedicated his
life to telling people that there are no
good Arguments for the existence of God
is the same guy who admits that he will
automatically reject any argument for
God's existence no matter how strong the
evidence is
the leaders of the new atheism haven't
examined the evidence for God's
existence and gone where the evidence
points they've set up a methodology that
is impervious to evidence for anything
they don't want to believe
my goodness if we wanted to play by
these rules we could just say that the
new atheists don't exist
but David of course the new atheists
exist we just watched some clips of
Richard Dawkins and Peter bagozian
what if we were hallucinating
what if this is a David Blaine magic
trick
what if alien tricksters want us to
think we just saw Peter bagozian
interviewing Richard Dawkins
what if what if what if
playing skeptic is easy my friends
now we've heard Clark's Third Law any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
I'm ready to lay down Woods first law
here it is
if you're going to reject an argument no
matter how good or bad the argument is
then the fact that you reject the
argument tells us absolutely nothing
about whether the argument is good or
bad
if you're going to reject an argument no
matter how good or bad the argument is
then the fact that you reject the
argument tells us absolutely nothing
about whether the argument is good or
bad
in other words Dawkins rejects all
Arguments for the existence of God
what does that tell us about how good or
bad these Arguments for the existence of
God are
absolutely nothing because Dawkins has
admitted that he will reject any
evidence no matter how strong it is
if God speaks to him Dawkins won't
believe in God if Jesus returns with a
chorus of angels Dawkins won't believe
in God if God writes a message in the
Stars Dawkins won't believe in God no
matter what the evidence is Dawkins
won't believe in God he admitted it
so when Dawkins declares that there's no
evidence for God's existence does that
tell us anything anything whatsoever
about whether there's evidence for God's
existence
no
and yet this is one of the guys whose
followers trust him to do their deep
thinking for them
of course if you explain this to them
they'll deny people who've been
manipulated and conditioned with cult
tactics usually don't realize they've
been manipulated and conditioned
so when you show them what's happened to
them don't expect them to thank you for
exposing the leader of their group
keep in mind I'm not talking about all
atheists here I'm referring to the ones
who've been programmed like Bots to run
around screaming show me the evidence
show me the evidence show me the
evidence that's no evidence that's no
evidence that's no evidence it's their
mantra
and it's incredibly difficult to get
them to see how their thoughts and
behavior have been conditioned because
now their self-esteem is connected to
their membership in their group
turns out that
sitting at your computer all day telling
people they're stupid because they're
not in your group does give you an easy
self-esteem boost
so criticizing their group is an attack
on the source of their worth and value
and this makes it extremely difficult to
show them how they've been manipulated
notice I said difficult not impossible
cult tactics can be undermined and
exposed
and I'm about to show you how
[Music]